heading into the weekend president
donald trump announced
an upcoming new super duper missile that
is not my term that's his
asked excuse me asked about it his press
secretary kaley mckennany
was uh saying she doesn't know anything
about it you got to go talk to the
pentagon so late last week donald trump
had an event in the oval office to
announce
the space force flag this is the newest
sort of
sub-branch of the military not really a
branch it encompasses the worst of
nationalism
the military-industrial complex
unbridled capitalism
and trump's delusions of grandeur all at
one it puts all of those together
there was a really funny moment when
trump went over to take a picture with
the space force flag
this is reality as far as we can tell
and something weird happened
the guy holding the flag sort of
flinched and almost dropped the flag
trump flinches
it's all a comedy of errors it's very
visual i admit but let's take a look at
it
that's fantastic isn't that great so
that was something but to get to the
real disaster porn
here is trump announcing the super duper
missile
incredible military equipment uh
at a level that nobody's ever seen
before we have no choice we have to do
it
with the adversaries we have out there
we have uh
they call it the super duper missile and
i heard the other night 17 times faster
than
what they have right now then you take
the fastest missile we have right now
you've heard russia has five times and
china's working on five or six times we
have won 17 times
and it's just gotten the go-ahead
17 times faster if you can believe that
general that's something right
sounds like we could uh we could really
kill a bunch of people at once with that
thing um really really exciting stuff
so trump says 17 times faster than what
we have right now
so i believe that our fastest missile
right now
is the brahmos also referred to as the
pj-10
that has a maximum speed of mach 3
meaning about three times the speed of
sound
that's like 2300 miles per hour so
17 times faster than that rough numbers
that's mach
51 that would be about 39 000 miles per
hour
that sounds weird i don't know about
that
about an hour later donald trump's press
secretary kayleigh mckennony was asked
about this the question alone was
hilarious and here's her answer
the president earlier in the oval office
said that the pentagon was developing a
quote
super duper missile uh pentagon was
asked about that shortly after the
president
made his remarks and declined to comment
referring it back to the white house so
i'm wondering if you can
say what the president was describing
yeah i would just refer you back to the
president mark remarks in the pentagon i
don't have any new information on that
at this point
so the pentagon as you heard there
referred questions back to the white
house
white house said nothing they said go
back to the pentagon and eventually
all that we got out of the pentagon was
dod is working
on developing a range of hypersonic
missiles no word on whether it's 17
times faster than our current fastest
missile nick schifrin from pbs news
newshour said
trump maybe was referring to the agm-183
which is a hypersonic missile approved
for purchase by the air force in
february
so there's some obvious low-hanging
fruit here like trump sounds like an
idiot talking about a super-duper
missile
there's low-hanging fruit in this may be
classified trump is again maybe being
irresponsible with classified info
that's nothing new
the real story for me here is look at
everything that's going on
and we're spending who knows how much
money on more new weapons
that are marginally better at killing
more people more quickly than what we
have right now
we still don't have enough coronavirus
testing we still don't
have a national tracing initiative
contact tracing initiative for the virus
we have people who got 1200 bucks and
they are arguing about whether anybody
is going to even get anything else
although it's starting to go
in that direction it's the latest just
disgusting enumeration
of our misguided priorities by the
federal government and as usual
another day just another embarrassment
from donald trump just
a chorus of ridicule a barrage of
embarrassment
after this once again i've got something
really cool today the first
500 people who see this video and go to
davidpakman.com
skill will get a premium membership to
skillshare for two months
for free skillshare is the online
learning community offering
thousands of classes on almost anything
you can imagine everything's taught by
experts
the classes get split up into bite-sized
lessons so even if you're really busy
like me
you can fit skillshare into your
schedule there are classes on
drawing painting photography video
editing web design running a small
business
and that's not even scratching the
surface i got some
great ideas from a recent class i took
called youtube success and even though
we've been on youtube for years i still
got
a lot out of it they have classes for
every skill level whether you want to
get better at something you're already
experienced in or you want to explore
something totally new
and like i said the first 500 people who
see this video and go to davidpakman.com
skill will get a completely free premium
membership for
two months giving you access to every
class
skillshare offers check it out i put the
link right underneath this video